ladies and gentlemen I Gary Hall being
the acting returning officer the
election held on Thursday the 8th of
June 2017 do hereby give notice that the
number of votes cast for each candidate
at the election is as follows Fenne
Steven John Liberal Democrats 1126 Hoyle
Lindsey Hobby Labour Party 30,000 700
Lagarde Peter Dino the Green Party 530
moon Caroline Jane the Conservative
Party 23,000 233 there 134 spoil ballot
papers but I can hereby declare that
Lindsey Harvey oil has been duly elected
thank you
[Applause]
can I first of all thank the returning
officer I think it's been good tonight
to get the result through so quickly
with the number of thoughts that's being
cast in Charlie tonight was like to do
is thank all the stuff involved in that
from the tone all right through the
polling stations obviously the police as
well under a very tense moment the
country is suffering from so I do thank
our police force the work that they do
throughout this country and especially
in Charlie tonigh of course we've got to
talk about the result this is a
fantastic result this is not a result I
ever expected it is a very clear
rejection of the attack on our services
the attack on our land HS the attack on
our Hospital the attack on our education
and our skills in calling this is a
reminder austerity is not to be taken
lightly and the people of choli
have no spoken they are rejected what
the government has offered the people of
charlie completely what we have said is
they want good public services they want
those services for all of us not for the
few and what we will see from now is
that we are brought people together in
jolly we've United a volunteer for the
Labor Party
on what is likely it was about a lot of
choice let's not kid ourselves I'm very
pleased to represent you all I am proud
we've been born and brought up in our
toe it is our tone that matters and our
tone whether it's rural or whether it's
urban there's spoken with one voice
so those doubters who say I only
represent a certain part that has been
well and truly rejected tonight as we've
seen in the ballot boxes
and I've gotta say there is a very clear
message for you keeping the rubbers in
the chilly Guardian the Conservative
Party may think alerts to the right by
joining forces that also has been
rejected tonight so maybe on the people
who go back to South Ribble may remind
themselves when they are but a bison
Chorley's let's wit with you kick you
Kip has also been rejected in Charlie
what I will says I am proud to represent
this town I will always put the people
of Charlie first so can I say thank you
to everybody but and thank you to all
the candidates but just remember the one
thing tonight it is the people of Chola
that matters it is our Hospital that
matters it's our school that matters and
the vault has proved it thank you
everybody